so I'm really glad you guys left a bit
because I have a few jokes at my slides
and if it was just deadpan silence is
like oh I better skip those slides okay
so I'm Dan I'm gonna be talking about
deep learning and tensorflow
with a bunch of cool visualizations I'd
like to ask first just to get a sense of
where the audience are like how many
people here would find going over deep
learning to be like redundant and not
that interesting okay a few people I
appreciate the honesty like I you know I
I hope that it will still be interesting
for you because I have some like cool
charts and figures and graphics that are
new and how many people would find an
intro to deep learning like useful and
interesting okay so there's a fair
number of people I won't feel bad that
I'm just like horribly boring you all
with the basics oh so a bit about me
first my name is Dan monnet I actually
came into machine learning from weird
direction which is to say a background
in data visualization and on the
tensorflow team so I'm part of Google
brain which is the team within Google
that's doing a lot of deep learning
research and has also created tensorflow
and I'm specifically responsible for a
tensor board which is this visualization
framework that's built into tensor flow
and if that's new to you don't worry
I'll also show it off but first let's
talk about deep learning so we really
mean deep neural networks for the most
part and for this I'm going to use a
bunch of materials made by my friend and
colleague Chris Ola if you haven't
encountered his name before he has a
really great blog on deep learning so if
you feel like oh wow those charts were
super helpful I highly recommend you
check it out there's lots of great
explanations there so artificial neural
networks are kind of inspired by regular
neural networks
I googled for what is a neuron and I got
this image of a typical neuron and you
can see that you have like okay it
connects to other neurons over here and
then it you know if you know a bit about
neurology which I don't it will sort of
get impulses for other neurons and maybe
fire and then trigger the other things
that's connected to so if we wanted to
turn it into a simple mathematical model
we might get something that looks kind
of
this it has some connections to other
things there's some kind of black box
and then it outputs some signal and we
can make this a bit more concrete we
could say okay they're going to be
weights on the connections maybe the
neuron is going to have some sort of B
which is a bias that like it uses as an
additional signal and whether or not
should fire and we could make this a
little bit more formal as this binary
threshold neuron so the way this works
is you basically sum over all of the
inputs times their respective weights
you add in a bias term and then if it is
greater than 0 you output 1 which is an
activation and if it's less than 0 you
output 0 so this is an extremely simple
model but interestingly enough out of
this really simple model you can build a
NAND neuron so you can look at this and
just kind of persuade yourself that it
simulates a NAND gate
and of course you can really build
anything out of NAND gates so what this
is telling you is that even if you take
a very simple model you get a
universality result you could build any
possible function any logical circuit
you could build a Turing machine out of
just enough of these neurons but the
real question is ok it's great that we
have this like way of expressing
functions that allows you in theory to
do any do anything but how are we gonna
train it how are we going to find the
right point in this massive parameter
space that will do something useful and
the answer is with calculus courtesy of
our most badass mathematical friend
Isaac Newton my impression is that this
is actually a pretty accurate depiction
of his character and to make it
trainable we're going to do to be
differentiable so this net this binary
threshold neuron is not really very good
for our purposes because this is not a
differentiable function the derivative
is always zero except for when it's
infinite so we could replace it with
some smooth function you know maybe you
would use a sigmoid in practice people
use something that's a little more hacky
called the Ray Lu but doesn't really
matter and now we have this sigmoid
neuron so that's great
and we probably want to have more than
one neuron because we need to represent
things with a lot of information so
we're going to organize them into layers
where you have a now you have the input
and then it Maps on to a new set of
inputs via some complicated set of
weights and then you have a bunch of
biases for each neuron and we can start
to play around with this and reorganize
it and realize oh hey that's just matrix
multiplication and vector addition and
then passing through a nonlinear
function so really this is the core idea
right now in neural networks or at least
in feed-forward neural networks is we're
going to have some input data we're
going to multiply it by matrix we're
going to add another vector and then
we're going to apply a nonlinear
transformation to that we can look at
that not as abstract algebra but as
geometry so in the geometric perspective
if we have two neurons we can imagine
okay the neurons are going to take some
point in a two dimensional space and
then through the activate
excuse me through the activation it's
going to map that point onto a different
point in a different two dimensional
space so we can start to look at the
layer as doing three things to the whole
space first we're going to stretch the
space then we're going to shift it which
is the bias ad and then finally we kind
of twist it a little bit with our
non-linearity so that's the whole
activity of neural networks we're going
to sort of stretch things a bit shift
them a bit and then squeeze them a bit
and the interesting thing about neural
networks is that it turns out by doing
lots of these stretches shifts and
squeezes we can start to learn
complicated functions so here's a simple
example we just want to separate these
two curves we could try to use a linear
separator and it's not going to be a
very good solution because this is not
linearly separable data what the neural
network does is it learns this sort of
curve that matches the data but the way
it does that is by mapping the data set
into a new representation where it is
linearly separable so in this case we
have just a single layer in between and
it starts with this input then the the
hidden representation with the two new
neurons is stretched and squeezed in
such a way that is separable a
then we can just output based on you
know hyperplane separator if we want so
let's look at a slightly more
complicated example which is a spiral
this graphic is showing us taking I
think it's a four layer neural network
that just repeatedly stretches shifts
and squeezes the spiral until we have
nice easily separable data at the end
and my talk is gonna come probably in
short stream as well watch this twice
okay so that's very exciting
but will be really exciting is if we had
some sort of sweet like JavaScript
interactive playground where we could
see this happening in real time and
localhost is not available what does
that
well I guess I could just entertain you
with my jokes early well I figure out
how to reconnect to this network so okay
this seems promising this thing which
I'm about to show you is not yet
available but we're going to release it
very soon probably within the next week
or two we're gonna put on the tensor
flow website so you can think of this as
a cool preview okay here we are so what
this is showing us is like a live
training of a neural network so let me
first just explain what's going on here
we have a data set that we want to
separate in this case it's a very simple
like cert concentric circles and we have
a sequence of neurons this one is
showing us they're sort of the input
neuron where we can see okay this one is
just the Y position this one is the x
position then the first layer is going
to learn some new transformations that
are combination of the previous layers
and in this case it just has some sort
of rotated planar separators and finally
it's going to have an output layer here
and right now it's just sort of a weird
goofy plain it's not really doing
anything very useful so let's try
chaining it now we can see that it's
okay it's starting to shift it starting
to figure out and then very quickly it
gets the correct representation and so
we can sort of use this to get a visual
intuition for what the neural network
was doing this first layer really was
just able to shift around these planes a
little bit but it shifted around planes
such that now you can take a linear
combination or a nearly linear
combination of these planes and
successfully get the circle
hi I'm Sir John Joe we actually even
have more neurons here than we need we
could take it down to just a single
hidden layer with three neurons and it
will eventually get the correct
representation but you do need three
neurons here if you try it with just two
it will kind of struggle endlessly but
it doesn't have enough information to
represent the real shape but it tries
you know that's better than 50% and we
can also look at this for harder
problems for example the spiral
and it's just kind of fun to explore
what these try to do so let's see it
actually has a lot of trouble getting
the spiral which if you think about it
if you want to figure out a way to like
deform these two planes to map onto the
spiral it's not an easy problem and it
tends to it tends to make some progress
eventually but let's see what happens oh
I took the learning rate down
yeah this is entirely local this is just
like another example of like you know I
ran this like five times before and like
okay you know it does something kind of
interesting sort of quickly so I can
probably just like watch it go but
naturally now it's not obliging it's
just kind of like stuck on this maybe we
can split the the dataset in half idea
so maybe we'll we'll kind of revisit
this in a little bit
once it has discovered something
interesting about this data set how it's
actually moving again okay so I'll
return to this and in the meantime I'll
go back to my slides
okay so this is more or less the the end
of my introduction to neural networks
but I'm going to allude to some other
interesting things that are happening in
the field
so what I've shown is the most basic
primitive piece of feed-forward neural
networks but there's a lot of different
structures that are quite interesting
for example convolutional nets this
these are really useful in image
recognition or any time when there's
repeated structure the way it basically
works is you're going to tie a lot of
the same weights so that you can learn
instead of if you imagine I'm showing
you an image if we were just doing the
feed-forward neural nets with the layers
and like in the previous diagram you
need to learn and new for every portion
of the image like what does an eye look
like what does an edge look like what
does a curve look like so the idea with
the convolutional net is that the lower
layers we're just going to have a lot of
repeated sub structure so it can learn
one concept of a curve or one concept of
a gradient that it can then apply
everywhere so basically all of the
modern image recognition techniques are
using confidence then we have recurrent
neural networks these are capable of
working with sequences of data so the
way it works is we have a single neural
network that conceptually like loops
back on itself so that if I were to give
you say you wanted to do a translation
model maybe you want to translate
English into French then what you could
do is feed into the neural network one
word at a time in sequence and then it
maintains state from one step to the
next so it can kind of remember like
okay if your previous word was V then
that changes the how to interpret the
subsequent word and then we also have LS
TMS this is a particularly where it now
has a complicated internal structure and
the basic idea was that with recurrent
neural networks they're not very good at
remembering things so L STM's have an
explicit mechanism by which they have
like quote unquote short-term memory and
long-term memory
so the short-term memory is just as in a
recurrent Network Network it just feeds
forward from step to step and the
long-term memory it has a gating
mechanism by which the neural network
can kind of
when it needs to remember things and
when it needs to forget things so this
way it could you know in the text
example it could pick on certain details
in the beginning of a paragraph that
maybe will be very important for
determining what the semantics of the
end of the paragraph are if you wanted
to see dem visualizations of this
there's a really great blog post called
the unreasonable effectiveness of
recurrent neural networks by Andre carp
Aarthi and in it he sort of goes step by
step with these lsdm kind of visualizing
what pieces is it remembering and what
pieces is it forgetting so I highly
recommend that there's also I'll just
mention a really cool result which I
don't have a diagram for as neural
Turing machines so this is a relatively
recent work by deep minds to create
neural networks that have differentiable
strategies for essentially learning
loops algorithms and writing to memory
where it's not just like one vector of
memory but it has a whole memory space
that it can read to and write to and
move around in so they've had some
success in teaching neural networks to
learn algorithms so it learns like basic
four loops I think it may have learned
to sort so there's very interesting
stuff so that's neural networks now I'm
going to talk a bit about tensor flow
tensor flow you probably all have heard
of it's Google's new open source
distributed computational framework and
it's being mostly applied right now for
deep learning but it actually has a lot
of broader applications but first I'm
going to talk a bit about the team that
made tensor flow which is Google brain
so Google brain is led by this guy named
Jeff Dean who you may have heard of
because he among other things came up
with
which of course Hadoop is based on but
mapreduces actually Jeff Dean is
incredibly prolific MapReduce is like
one of many systems he created so the
external stuff is like leveldb protobuf
internally spanner BigTable basically
all of googles great distributed
database systems he also built the first
implementation of like Google
advertising surveying and worked on a
huge a phenomenal array of Google
products and core technologies so where
the rest of the world has Chuck Norris
jokes you know like Chuck Norris what's
going on
Chuck Norris can slam a revolving door
this kind of stuff
Google has Jeff Dean facts so some of my
favorite Jeff Dean facts one is the
speed of light used to be 140 miles an
hour then Jeff spent a weekend
optimizing it compilers don't warn Jeff
Dean Jeff Dean warns compilers
and my personal favorite Jeff Dean puts
on his pants one leg at a time but if he
had a larger number of legs you would
realize his approach actually scales as
ov log n I really appreciate any crowd
where I can make asymptotic runtime
jokes but the fun fact about about how
this applies is the Jeff Dean also
designed tensorflow attention flow is
actually his second attempt at making
like distributed deep learning the first
one was called disbelief and like it was
successful but it wasn't really good
enough for Jeff so about a year ago we
started working on this new system and
then open sourced in November so what is
tensorflow
well fun fact you know just this is an
aside there's a naive model of producing
talks in which you start working and you
have no slide deck and then you finish
working you have one slide deck so you
think okay there's some sort of positive
correlation between the amount of work
you do and the number of slide decks you
have but in reality if you don't work
enough you may wind up with two slide
decks and that is situation I'm instance
I didn't get all of my animations to
transfer over to this javascript thing
so we go on to the second slide deck so
I'm going to take a very very kind of
literal approach to explaining what
tensorflow is which is say I'm going to
explain first what are what's flowing in
second what are tensors oh let me
actually ask this how many of you guys
already know how tensor flow works and
like data flow graphs you've been using
the API this would just be boring for
you okay approximately no one that's
great because like I said my talk is
going to come in under time so really
like the more things I have to go over
okay so tensor flow is all about
specifying computational graphs if I
alluded to the fact that it's being used
for deep learning but could be in fact
used for a lot of other applications
that's because it has is really sort of
abstract low-level semantics called
structure so in it you have these graphs
and the nodes represent copy
so in this case I've made an node that
represents adding two numbers and a node
that represents squaring a number and we
can just feed in some numbers and kind
of pass through the system and we'll get
our result the nice thing about this is
we could use it for a lot more than just
addition and simple arithmetic we could
also use it for example matrix
multiplication matrix or vector addition
and sigmoid functions which is to say
that all of the pieces of neural
networks we're going to get in this
computational graph framework and just
for an example you know we might
represent handwritten digits like this
would be a number one in a mist
represented as an array where the
intensities are the pixel darkness so
that's what's flowing sorry that's the
graph what's flowing across the graph
are tensors tensors are really just like
the arbitrary dimension generalization
of scalars vectors and matrices so we
could say this is zero tensor or 1
tensor a 2 tensor a 3 tensor you can
have arbitrary dimensionality of the
data so very commonly you'll have a like
a 4 tensor for images where the first
dimension is your batch size so you're
grouping lots of related you can have
lots of examples together for efficiency
the second and third dimensions are the
pixel like the actual position of pixels
in the images and the fourth dimension
contains the color channels so with that
we have data flow graphs and we just
need some added pieces so tensor flow is
going to have a mechanism for storing
persistent state that is to say like
weights can be stored within the graph
then it has mechanisms for bringing an
input so you can set up queues that will
like read data out of a database and
pass it through your graph and then in
the output it makes predictions so let's
look at an actual example of a small
tensor flow graph to make this a bit
more concrete so this would be a small
graph that has a single layer neural
network so here is the layer itself at
the bottom we have a matrix
multiplication and a bias ad
linearity so it's exactly the same basic
pieces and then maybe we need to go and
take the hidden layer and convert it
down to the number of classes we want to
predict for a regression so we would
have here just another matrix
multiplication a number bias addition
some of the really interesting stuff
about tensor flow is what happens up
here so in neural networks it's
relatively simple to build a
feed-forward neural network that just
does inference or makes predictions but
what becomes a lot harder is training it
so I haven't really discussed the
training of neural networks in my
overview but the idea is we're going to
because the neural network is a
differentiable function we can treat the
whole function as producing an error as
a function of the parameters of the
network so conceptually like I have this
little proto M mist Network I there's
trying to predict handwritten digits and
I feed it all of the examples of
handwritten digits that I have and it
does maybe a terrible job like it just
has no idea what a zero is there's no
idea what a1 is but I can now say
compute the mistake that it made and
compute the derivative of that mistake
with respect to all of the parameters in
the network and then start to minimize
that
so what tensorflow does that's really
nice here is all of that work of
figuring out how to compute the
derivatives of your graph and minimize
it
it handles implicitly it's called Auto
differentiation so what that means is
that you as the network designer can
just specify like ok I kind of want
these like feed-forward networks
feed-forward layers maybe I want to one
be convolutional maybe I want to choose
my loss function very very carefully but
then all of the work of figuring out how
to train that network tensorflow will do
for you so what happens in this example
is we have some data that flows upward
through the network we make a bunch of
predictions and then we compute a loss
function based on the predictions versus
the actual labels in the data and then
it enters this sort of magical black box
for us and the result is that the
network is trained and we can keep on
working with it back to the first slide
deck so one might say okay like that's
great that this computational system
you've described can train and simulate
neural networks but it also looks really
complicated like in the previous layer
we just had like
a matrix multiplication bias add an
addition and we just wanted like glue
these layers together why do we need to
think about all of this other stuff why
do we need to learn about computational
graphs and interestingly enough they
actually the first approach that we took
for doing deep learning at Google looks
very different dis to belief really did
just have a layer and you kind of would
say like okay I want this kind of layer
I want that kind of layer on with this
kind of layer I'll plug them all
together please like train it for me and
it was a much simpler API there are few
advantages of this approach one is that
we want to be able to do really
complicated things and specifically the
brain team has a lot of researchers who
are trying to push forward the cutting
edge of neural networks and if you just
give them like a black box that is a
layer it's really not good enough
so having this really low-level
representation means that whatever kind
of complicated neural network you can
imagine you can implement very naturally
in tensor flow so like there's no way
you're going to fit a neural Turing
machine into a layer based sort of
straightforward layer based system
without a lot of work by the core
developers but here anyone can start to
tinker on minut details of a network and
experiment with it
the other nice thing is that you know
Jeff denoting from MapReduce this guy
really cares about how things scale
across large clusters of machines and
the potential flow graph framework makes
it easy to partition up the work either
with data parallelism or Model Model
parallelism across lots of machines and
lots of GPUs and actually earlier this
year we open-source the distributed
implementation so anyone can use this to
build a highly scalable machine learning
system a few other advantages is that
it's is really portable so we actually
have Android and I believe iOS
implementations for tensorflow it's
really flexible as I said not only could
you use it to iterate on kind of custom
neural network implementations but you
could also use it for totally different
tasks so I know that people are thinking
of using tensorflow for physics
simulations
I know that there's an active effort to
use tensorflow for other machine
learning models like regressions random
forests this kind of thing so you can
potentially use it for a lot of tasks
and finally it's open source
but that said it is really complicated
and it becomes even more complicated
when you think about how deep
cutting-edge neural networks are
becoming so here's a neural network from
1998
it's called limb net it was I believe
the first convolution neural and there
on that or at least the first successful
one and it is like 11 boxes deep each
one of these boxes represents like a
function essentially so the I was
showing before with the flowing graphic
would be about three boxes in this
representation since 1998 let's look at
what had happened by 2012 this is Alex
net it was the first neural network to
win the image net competition that's a
big image recognition challenge and
since 2012 the image net competition has
been only won by neural networks so over
this period about doubled in size the
follow-on to Alex net was Google a net
that was another winning image Nets
obsession sub image Nets submission and
we can see it now so like if you thought
that the diagram that I showed on the
other slide was complicated just imagine
if it were 100 times larger and then of
course this is 2014 so you can expect
like that sanction history at this point
the most reason when I have a diagram
for is called inception v3 this was our
submission for the most recent image net
competition is the error rates for image
net have been decreasing exponentially
so at this point it's basically a solved
contest we kind of need to find
something harder to do with our time but
here is Inception v3
so the interesting thing about neural
networks is they're like really good at
solving problems we would like to use
them for some very important things so
one thing which Google is using neural
networks for is the automatic reply
generation in inbox I don't know if any
of you use inbox for your email but it
will try to like figure out what you
want to say and say it for you so okay
if our if we don't get what our neural
network is doing then maybe that's not
so bad because it just like gives you a
goofy reply and you go on with your life
just don't send that but we're also
using neural networks for self-driving
cars and there we really want to be able
to understand kind of a bit better what
it's doing really want to be able to
debug it I really want to be able to
monitor it and the self-driving car
neural network is going to be a lot more
complicated than just an image
recognition I mean this would be
essentially a sub module in a
self-driving car so let's see what we
can do about that
and the basic answer is we need
visualizations this is going to be a way
that we can start to get intuition about
neural networks and start to iterate on
our ideas so to that end we've built a
system called tensor board tensor board
is like a general-purpose data
visualizing system that is attached to
tensor flow in this case we have a very
simple neural network that is more or
less the same as the flowing graphic I
showed earlier except now it's
interactive and we can start to start to
explore it so maybe we can see okay you
know at the high level we're going to
have two layers this layer is going to
have a matrix multiply and bias add and
then there's going to be this rayleigh
function the activation then maybe we'll
apply dropout and then it'll connect to
layer two and at each step we can now
just check how is our neural network
wired and start to get some
understanding of what exactly it's doing
in this example of the this eminence
model like maybe it's overkill it's
simple enough that you can understand it
on your own on its own but we can also
apply it to this like crazy network that
was so big that it no longer fits on my
screen and here it just starts to be a
little bit more tractable
although this is actually this is
actually a 44 megabyte text file that
I'm loading because the graph is really
that large but now we can see that okay
we've got kind of a corresponding
structure where it's this tall tower and
then in each piece we open it up and we
can see that it's composed of these sub
towers that are doing different things
and we can start to kind of explore this
graph does a lot of clever things to
make it so that these really complicated
structures can be rendered efficiently
we're actually publishing a research
paper discussing all of the tricks we
put into this but one one thing in
particular is that it uses color codings
so to identify repeated substructures so
I can tell that all of these pink pieces
are going to have the exact same nodes
within them and a little bit of history
when we first bit built tensorflow
we had a hell of a time getting it to
just do the right thing on the image
recognition challenge so they were like
I'm there was a month and a half where
we had built this really incredible
system and it just wasn't working and we
couldn't tell like is this some minor
bug that we need to fix because somebody
made like an oopsie typo or is there
something fundamentally wrong with the
approach to how the system scales that's
going to cause it to get inferior
results and it turned out that in the
our image net model we had just had a
little bit of a miss coating so that one
of the layers was missing some crucial
connections and that's the kind of thing
which now with this tool we would have
been able to catch in you know hours
instead of weeks but we can do more than
just visualize the network we can also
collect information about how training
is progressing so for example maybe you
want to track how your accuracy is
changing over time or how the cross
entropy is changing over time then
tensor board is able to connect your
process and just record the data and
show it to you as training progresses
and this all just fits into the same
tensor flow graph structure which is to
say that you know we have ops that do
things like matrix multiplication we
have ops that do thing like saving
variables and updating them we also have
an OP that exports data to tensor board
so that means that you really are free
to like come up with your own
complicated metrics and insert them into
the graph and then be able to track end
realize them and here I just have a
couple kind of simple examples another
thing you might want to do is visualize
images Pat traveling through tensorflow
it could be as simple as I just want to
understand what does my input data look
like or it could be that you're working
on like say a self-driving car and you
want it to generate images representing
its knowledge of what is in the what it
thinks is in the road so you can see
like what was it doing tensor board
supports that used case another thing it
does is shows you distributions of data
so if you have some tensor that you want
to visualize you can save off a
histogram and I'm gonna explain this
visualization because it's a little bit
interesting and it's also a little bit
bad I think it's little bit interesting
the ways that it's a little bit bad so
what we what the tensor flow backend is
producing is you can just serialize any
tensor and it produces this histogram
where it has a bunch of really small
bins showing the layout of the data this
was my first take at visualizing that
data and what it's doing is it's showing
the evolution of this distribution over
time but it's only showing percentile
summary statistics so what I mean by
that is that like the thickest we can
take this as an example or this slightly
more interesting one
so here the the line in the center is
showing how the median of the data
changed this area is showing how one
half standard deviation above the median
changed this is one standard deviation
this is one and a half standard
deviations this is two this is two
standard deviations this isn't the max
so it lets you it basically kind of
assumes that your data is normally
distributed and then shows you how that
normal distribution changed over time so
sometimes this is kind of nice and
useful like we can see okay this is the
biases in the network and the biases
were kind of spreading out over time but
at the same time remaining contained so
maybe we can get some interesting
intuition about what the system is doing
but the problem is that it really breaks
down entirely on bimodal data if we had
a bimodal distribution like here in here
then because we're only seeing the top
level summary statistic it would just
show up as a solid black box so not
really what you want also I called it a
histogram display but it really is not
showing histograms it's showing these
like area charts
so I recently recently got a really
fantastic colleague forever my let's
guests 45 yeah so I recently got the
pleasure of working with this guy named
Sean Carter who joined the brain team to
try to build more useful visualizations
for understanding neural nets before
that he did a bunch of work of the New
York Times he's also a music fan and he
saw this Joy Division album cover and
thought well you know it's nice album
but wouldn't it be a nice for data
visualization so what he did to solve
the histogram problem was built this
dashboard where now we can see we're
still seeing these histograms evolving
over time but the direction of time is
up so each one of these slices is I
think further in the past so it's like
the president is here the past is there
and now we can sort of get a sense like
I always view it like I'm doing some
mountain range in a beautiful distant
country but now you can really see
exactly how the distribution evolved
over time without the losing all this
information by treating it as though
it's a normal distribution and if my
demo will work I can even do so this
demo has been really misbehaving we'll
see okay wait for this I don't know why
opening the developer tools
it wasn't knows it's being watched no
computers they're the absolute worst
okay there we go yeah I just think
that's really cool like it's it's I'm
sure useful to someone but I'm mostly
just like watching this move around
and know in all seriousness when you
when you shift it like this it becomes a
lot easier to see how the differences
relate to each other so this one it's
like useful for seeing how it evolved
over time but really difficult to say
like how tall is this compared to this
compared to this and on this view you
can't view it over time but you can very
clearly see how the shape moved so
between the two of them I think it's a
pretty useful tool and we're going to
put this into tensor board shortly so
yeah that's my talk I was worried I
would come in under time but it turns
out I'm like exactly on target and I'm
planned to post these slides online at
that URL I'm not sure if they're there
right now the playground that I showed
is going to be posted to the tensorflow
site hopefully within the next week I
think if you watch hacker news it will
probably show up there and if you want
to learn more about neural networks I
really strongly recommend Chris ollas
blog because it's a phenomenal resource
and if you want to learn more about
tensor flow we have a whole bunch of
tutorials posted on our website and with
that I would be happy to take your
questions
yes
so the question was can we use tensor
board to debug the vanishing or
exploding gradient problem that's a
really good question right now I would
say not really but that's one of the
things that I want to tackle so we have
a you know full development effort going
forward on tensor board one of the
places that I would like to get to is
using tensor board as a full kind of
debugger for the tensor flow system
where you can use it to you know if you
imagine using a regular debugger the
really nice thing is that lets you get
in sort of in the middle of the
computation and see what the state is
and how everything relates so what I
want to do with tensor board is get to
the point where you can set kind of
detect interesting criteria and how your
graph is evolving and then dump the full
state of the tensor flow graph and
examine it in tensor board so the way I
imagine that would be working is like if
we could go into this graph and every
point sort of click on an edge that
represents a tensor and see the
distribution of values there so that
when you have like a vanishing gradient
you can kind of see okay which point
exactly did it vanish or maybe if
something goes to nan like where did the
first nan appear so the answer is not
yet but we're working on it yes I know
Google is using it in production I'm not
sure I yeah I suspect the answer is yes
but I don't know yes
that's an interesting question so right
now the tensor board graph Explorer is
very tightly tied to the way that
tensorflow represents graphs however I
do know of teams that have taken their
own graphical structure and kind of
turned it into a fake tensor flow graph
so that it would be visible in the graph
Explorer so I would say like hacky but
possible yes
right so the question is can we use the
graph Explorer to create tensor flow
graphs this is something we've talked
about a lot because it would be really
cool you know it's interesting right
people always want to have graphical
like GUI creators for code and it's sort
of a very mixed history at best we I
can't really think of many tools that
people actually use but I think that's
definitely something we'd like to try as
an experimental project and see how it
turns out I think that particularly what
we'll want to do is once we have a
really stable patterns around how one
sets up tensor flow graphs like wiring
the input and output bits then we start
to be more promising to have an
interactive builder you can like drop in
a layer choose the parameters for it
wire them together and have that spit
out the code but it's not something
that's on our near-term agenda as like
something something serious I think that
if somebody were to want to fork this
and like try it out that'd be extremely
cool and then that'd be a nice way to
test it out and see if we should
integrate it back in other questions yes
I don't like empirically that seems to
be the way that everyone does it I mean
I think it's it's a really interesting
question you know you can just hyper
parameter search is a very difficult
problem and that's one thing we do want
to tackle intense report is like giving
the ability to visualize how your
hyperparameters search progressed like
what seemed to matter
I always just personally think it'd be
really cool to try to leverage neural
networks to figure out like learn how to
structure in neural networks but I don't
have anything concrete for you yes oh
great question Wow it gots oh you know I
think that it paused when I was out of
the tabbed so it's because it's only on
this runs of iteration yeah we can leave
this on as our background for any
questions yes sorry could you say it
again yes a great question I think that
let me this my link may not work cuz
this is an internal Google link but we
do have that capability and let's see if
I can load it for you yeah so actually
I'll show a couple other things we're
working on so this one is now
visualizing by device which i think is
what you're asking it's showing like the
different colors represent which devices
we've put the nodes on so you can kind
of see like okay this one is is split
between two different devices and most
of them are on the blue device which is
not really me immediately meaningful to
me what that is
we also have tensor shapes so this is an
example where you can see on each edge
what is the dimensionality of the tensor
that's passing through we also have this
we're starting to put in performance
statistics into the graph so here's an
example where we can color the nodes by
compute time and we can see okay
computing gradients is like almost all
of the compute and then as we dig into
that
it's like maybe a particular matrix
multiplication is expensive yeah like
this Matt mole is one of the most
expensive ops in actually training this
graph we can also visualize the color by
memory usage and now we see okay really
again the same Matt mole is by far the
most memory expensive operation here yes
any other questions all right thanks
hope you enjoyed